>>> WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IN PERIL AS
THE COUNTRY ALREADY LOOKS AHEAD
TOWARD THE 2024 RACE FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP WORKING
HARDER THAN EVER TO SPREAD HIS
BIG LIE THAT THE 2020 ELECTION
THAT HE LOST WAS STOLEN.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD IS JOINING US.
HE'S GOT NEW DETAILS FOR US.
BRIAN, TRUMP'S BIG LIE FUELED
THAT JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION.
AND NOW THE SELECT COMMITTEE IN
THE HOUSE, THEIR INVESTIGATION
IS CLEARLY INTENSIFYING.
>> THAT INVESTIGATION IS AT A
CRITICAL STAGE, WOLF.
TRUMP'S FORMER AIDES AND THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HIMSELF SEEM
READY TO DO BATTLE WITH THE
COMMITTEE AS TRUMP CONTINUES TO
HOLD CAMPAIGN-STYLE RALLIES.
>> I'M THRILLED TO BE BACK.
>> Reporter: TONIGHT, NEW
CONCERNS THAT FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP, HIS ALLIES AND SUPPORTERS
CONTINUE TO STOKE THE FLAMES OF
THE BIG LIE THAT THE LAST
ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
AND ARE SETTING THE STAGE FOR A
WORRISOME PERIOD LEADING TO THE
2024 VOTE.
TRUMP AND HA LIES ARE IN A
SERIOUS SHOWDOWN WITH THE HOUSE
SELECT COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING
THE JANUARY 6th ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL.
AND THE NEXT FEW DAYS WILL BE
CRITICAL.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS WAIVED
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE ALLOWING THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES TO SEND
DOCUMENTS WHICH COULD SHED LIGHT
ON WHETHER ANYONE IN TRUMP'S
WHITE HOUSE INNER CIRCLE MAY
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
INSURRECTION.
ADAM SCHIFF, A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE, WAS ASKED BY CBS WHEN
THE COMMITTEE WILL GET THOSE
DOCUMENTS.
>> WE, SHOULD I THINK, GET THOSE
DOCUMENTS SOON BECAUSE THE
SITTING PRESIDENT HAS THE
PRIMARY SAY ON EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THESE WITNESSES COME IN AND
TESTIFY.
>> BUT THAT MAY NOT HAPPEN.
OF THE FOUR FORMER TRUMP AIDES
SUBPOENAED FOR DOCUMENTS AND
TESTIMONY, TWO OF THEM, FORMER
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
MARK MEADOWS AND FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY AIDE KASH PATEL ARE
SAID TO BE COMMUNICATE WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
THE THIRD, DAN SCAVINO WAS
FINALLY PHYSICALLY SERVED WITH A
SUBPOENA AFTER SEVERAL DAYS OF
COMMITTEE STAFFERS TRYING TO
FIND HIM.
AND THE FOURTH, FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE STRATEGIST STEVE
BANNON HAS INDICATED THROUGH HIS
LAWYER HE'LL NOT COOPERATE WITH
THE "AT ALL, PROMPTING LEADERS
OF THE "TO REFER ANYONE WHO
DOESN'T COOPERATE TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOR POSSIBLE CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT CHARGES.
THIS COMES AS MORE GOP LEADERS
SEEM TO BE FALLING FIRMLY IN
LINE WITH TRUMP.
CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE, THE
NUMBER TWO REPUBLICAN IN THE
HOUSE, WAS PRESSED REPEATEDLY ON
FOX NEWS SUNDAY ON WHETHER HE
THOUGHT THE 2020 ELECTION WAS
STOLEN AND REPEATEDLY, REREFUSED
TO ANSWER.
>> LAST TIME, I PROMISE.
DO YOU THINK THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN OR NOT?
I UNDERSTAND YOU THINKIRREGULAR
THAT NEED TO BE FIXED.
>> IT'S NOT JUST IRREGULARITIES.
IT'S STATES THAT DID NOT FOLLOW
THE LAW SET WHICH THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO FOLLOW.
>> Reporter: AND CHUCK GRASSLEY
OF IOWA WHO VOTED TO CERTIFY THE
2020 ELECTION RESULTS AND
EARLIER THIS YEAR SLAMMED TRUMP
FOR CLAIMING THE ELECTION HAD
BEEN STOLEN STOOD WITH TRUMP AT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S RALLY IN
IOWA THIS WEEKEND AND ACCEPTED
TRUMP'S ENDORSEMENT FOR HIS
RE-EL
RE-ELECTION BID.
>> IF I DIDN'T ACCEPT THE
ENDORSEMENT OF SOMEONE WHO HAS
91% OF THE REPUBLICAN VOTERS IN
IOWA, I WOULDN'T BE TOO SMART.
I'M SMART ENOUGH TO ACCEPT THAT
ENDORSEMENT.
>> Reporter: TRUMP HIMSELF AT
THAT SAME RALLY CONTINUING TO
STOKE THE BIG LIE.
>> AND ACTUALLY, WE WON BY A
LOT.
THEY RIGGED THE ELECTION AND
NOW, BASED ON THE RIGGED
ELECTION, THEY'RE DESTROYING OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: ON HIS HBO SHOW
"REAL TIME," BILL MAHER WARNED
OF A SLOW-MOVING TRUMP COUP.
>> TRUMP WILL RUN IN 2024.
HE WILL GET THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION.
AND WHATEVER HAPPENS, ON
ELECTION NIGHT, HE'LL ANNOUNCE
HE WON.
>> Reporter: OVER THE WEEKEND,
RECORDING A VIDEO PRAISING
CAPITOL RIOTER ASHLI BABBITT ON
THE OCCASION OF HER BIRTHDAY AND
DEMANDING JUSTICE FOR BABBITT.
TRUMP AND HIS SUPPORTERS HAVE
SOUGHT TO MAKE ASHLI BABBITT A
MARTYR.
SHE WAS SHOT AND KILLED JANUARY
6th AS SHE TRIED TO BREAK
THROUGH A WINDOW TO THE
SPEAKER'S LOBBY.
INVESTIGATORS HAVE CONCLUDED SHE
APPEARED TO THREATEN LAWMAKERS
AND THE CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER
WHO SHOT HER HAS NOT BEEN
DISCIPLINED OR CHARGED.
>> BRIAN TODD REPORTING FOR US.
>>> LET'S GET MORE ON THIS.
OUR CHIEF POLITICAL ANALYST
GLORIA BORGER, FORMER OHIO
GOVERNOR JOHN KASICH AND CHIEF
LEGAL ANALYST JEFFREY TOOBIN IS
WITH US AS WELL.
THE AUTHOR OF "TRUE CRIMES AND
MISDE
MISDEMEANORS: THE INVESTIGATION
OF DONALD TRUMP."
AFTER THE JANUARY 6th ATTACK,
REPUBLICANS, INCLUDING SENATOR
CHUCK GRASSLEY CALLED ON FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT LESS
THAN A YEAR LATER, GRASSLEY
WOULD STAND BY TRUMP'S SIDE AS
HE SPOUTS NEW ELECTION
CONSPIRACY?
>> WOLF, CRAVEN AMBITION.
TOTAL HYPOCRISY.
WHAT CHUCK GRASSLEY SAID AFTER
JANUARY 6th WAS EVEN WORSE THAN
WHAT YOU JUST QUOTED.
HE ACCUSED DONALD TRUMP OF
BELITTLING AND HARASSING ELECTED
OFFICIALS ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO
GET HIS WAY AND ACCUSED THE
PRESIDENT OF EXTREME AGGRESSIVE
AND IRRESPONSIBLE BEHAVIOR.
AND THERE HE IS ACCEPTING HIS
ENDORSEMENT BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP
IS POPULAR IN HIS STATE AT THE
AGE OF 88.
HE HAS DECIDED TO RUN FOR
RE-ELECTION.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO WAS IN THE
CAPITOL THAT DAY AND HAD TO HIDE
FROM THE INSURRECTIONISTS.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO SHOULD KNOW
BETTER.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO, THROUGHOUT
HIS POLITICAL CAREER, HAS BEEN
ON THE SIDE OF WHISTLEBLOWERS
AND THE OTHER DAY HE SAID THAT
DONALD TRUMP DID ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING WRONG IN HIS OFFICE ON
JANUARY 3rd WHEN HE WAS TRYING
TO PRESSURE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO FIX THE ELECTION.
SOMETHING HAS HAPPENED WITH
CHUCK GRASSLEY, AND HE WANTS TO
GET RE-ELECTED AND KNOWS DONALD
TRUMP CAN HELP HIM GET THERE IN
IOWA.
>> THE RANKING MEMBER OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
BEEN IN THE SENATE FOR SO MANY
YEARS.
YOU'D THINK HE'D KNOW BETTER
THAN THIS, BUT --
>> HE DOES.
>> CLEARLY HE'S GOT POLITICAL
AMBITIONS EVEN AT THIS STAGE IN
HIS CAREER.
>> A REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN
LIZ CHENEY SAYS, AND I'M QUOTING
HER NOW, PERPETUATING THE BIG
LIE IS AN ATTACK ON THE CORE OF
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
UNDEMOCRATIC MOVEMENT, ISN'T IT?
>> LET ME BE VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT
ONE THREAT.
AND THIS CAME UP IN STEVE
SCALISE'S INTERVIEW WITH FOX
YESTERDAY.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE NOW TALKING
ABOUT IS USING STATE
LEGISLATURES TO VOTE AFTER THE
ELECTION TO SEEK OR NOT SEEK THE
TOP VOTE WINNER IN THAT STATE.
COULD BE THE VOTE FOR PRESIDENT.
COULD BE THE VOTE FOR OTHER
STATEWIDE OFFICIALS.
BUT THINK ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS NOW BECOMING AN OFFICIAL
POSITION OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
THAT REPUBLICAN STATE
LEGISLATURES IN STATES LIKE
PENNSYLVANIA, IN IOWA, IN
FLORIDA, CAN VOTE NOT TO CERTIFY
THE ACTUAL RESULTS, BUT PUT
THEIR FAVORITE CANDIDATE IN.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SEVERAL
STATES ARE CONSIDERING DOING,
AND IT IS SHOCKING THAT IT
HASN'T GOTTEN MORE ATTENTION FOR
THE ANTI-DEMOCRATIC ACT THAT IT
IS, BUT THIS IS WHERE WE ARE
HEADING, AND THIS IS WHAT I
THINK BILL MAHER, YOU KNOW, WHO
MAY BE A COMEDIAN, BUT HE SURE
KNEW WHAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
LAST NIGHT.
>> IT'S NOT FUNNY.
T.
>> IT WAS VERY, VERY POWERFUL.
DO YOU APPEAR TRUMP WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL IN PURGING ANY
MEMBERS OF THE GOP WHO WOULD
STAND UP TO HIM, IF -- IF HE
ATTEMPTS ANOTHER COUP DOWN THE
ROAD?
>> WELL, LOOK, FIRST OF ALL, I
LIKE BILL MAHER.
HE'S BEEN ON ALL SIDES.
HE'S BEEN CRITICIZING THE LEFT
AS MUCH AS THE RIGHT.
IT'S REALLY BEEN REMARKABLE WHAT
HE'S BEEN DOING.
I THINK THERE'S ONE IMPORTANT
THING TO REMEMBER HERE.
AND THAT IS, THESE LEGISLATORS
DIDN'T DO THAT.
AND I UNDERSTAND THE PUSH IS TO
GET THEM TO DO IT.
AND I AM CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I
WAS THE MOST PROMINENT
REPUBLICAN TO BE AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP.
TO FIGHT AGAINST DONALD TRUMP
AND WHAT HE STOOD FOR.
BUT I THINK TO SOME DEGREE
MAHER, THE THINGS HE HAD TO SAY,
HE WAS CONNECTING A LOT OF DOTS.
AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT JEFF
TOOBIN SAID BUT I HAVE TO ALSO
SAY, I STILL BELIEVE AT THE END
OF THE DAY THERE HAS TO BE SUCH
A VAST CONSPIRACY TO OVERTURN
THIS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE COURTS
INVOLVED.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE LOCAL ELECTION
OFFICIALS INVOLVED.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SECRETARIES OF
STATE INVOLVED.
I THINK IT'S A BRIDGE TOO FAR.
BUT LOOK, IT'S WHY I'VE NEVER
BEEN FOR TRUMP AND I DON'T
INTEND TO BE FOR TRUMP AND SHAME
ON SOMEBODY LIKE GRASSLEY.
I THINK GRASSLEY PROBABLY HAS
TERRIBLE ADVISERS WHO ARE CLOSE
TO TRUMP WHO TALKED THIS GUY
INTO THIS.
AND IT'S -- GLORIA IS RIGHT
ABOUT HIM.
HE'S NEVER BEEN THIS WAY.
AND HE'S 88, SEARCHING FOR
RE-ELECTION, AND IT'S PRETTY
SAD.
>> YOU AND I HAVE COVERED
GRASSLEY OVER THESE MANY YEARS.
IT'S SAD TO SEE HOW HE'S FLIPPED
IN RECENT WEEKS.
>> IT IS.
AND YOU HAVE TO SAY IT'S ABOUT
HIS RE-ELECTION BUT IF YOU TAKE
A STEP BACK, WHAT THIS IS IS
ABOUT CO-OPTING THE REPUBLICAN
ESTABLISHMENT.
THAT PICTURE OF CHUCK GRASSLEY
SMILING NEXT TO DONALD TRUMP
SAYING, OF COURSE IT WOULD BE SO
SMART.
I'M SO SMART TO ACCEPT THIS,
KNOW, ENDORSEMENT.
IS TRUMP CO-OPTING PEOPLE.
AND WITH GRASSLEY STANDING
THERE, YOU CAN LOOK AT THAT AND
SAY, OH, LOOK.
HE'S GOT THE SUPPORT OF ONE OF
THE KEY PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES SENATE.
WAIT A MINUTE.
THAT'S OKAY.
AND BE THE WHAT DO OTHER
SENATORS DO?
DO THEY FALL IN LINE BEHIND
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE THEY'RE
WORRIED?
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT IS THAT DONALD
TRUMP'S AGENDA COULD BECOME
THEIR AGENDA.
AND A LOT OF THEM DON'T WANT IT
BECAUSE HIS AGENDA IS ONE THING.
RELITIGATING 2020.
THEIR AGENDA IS RUNNING AGAINST
JOE BIDEN ON IMMIGRATION,